[Music]
so today for the cancellation i think my
job is pretty easy i need only pass
the cancellation mike the baton to an
unnamed woman
as yet unnamed
on the subway who um
different subway from the inside edition
thing
who took matters into her own hands to
cancel a disgusting pornographic ad
campaign by the dating app okay cupid
okcupid has littered subways and other
areas in many major cities with posters
and billboards
advertising its services with messages
declaring that okcupid is for every
single pansexual
every single non-monogamist
every single vaxxer and there's a
close-up picture of two people french
kissing with their tongues apparently
melded together there it is you can see
that
um every single tree hugger with a
picture of a half-naked guy with a
potted plant shoved on his underwear
they've also plastered signs that say
things like it's okay to have strong
convictions and abandon them for a night
and it's okay to only date someone who's
pro-choice and many other messages in
that vein
while this woman on the train decided
that
she didn't approve of this campaign and
was worried that children would see it
and be influenced by it so she responded
by going through the train and simply
tearing all the posters down herself
pretty great stuff check it out
i don't know for kids to be looking at
this is that okay
no it's not it's wrong this is
propaganda yeah
normalizing normalizing the next
generation
yeah this is why no like no one sees us
no this is disgusting because tv told
them not to not to get that not to get
to divide and upset us the government is
against us and you guys don't see it
okay
this is going to go away it's never
going to go away
so we the people say we don't want this
anymore
beautiful sight to behold there not the
posters but
this woman doing what needs to be done
this is of course exactly the correct
response to the insane filth that's
shoved down our throats and our kids
throats everywhere we go
the correct response is not
tolerance it's not politeness it's not
to be passive or nonchalant
it's not to transcribe all of our
grievances in an email
and fired off to okcupid customer
service center just so they can ignore
it or rather gather around on their
lunch break and laugh at it
the right approach is to remove the
filth yourself
intolerance for it
intolerance is a virtue
one of the biggest mistakes we ever made
in this culture and as conservatives
is to believe the lie that tolerance is
is is a universal virtue that it's a
universal good
and that you're somehow a good person
that how good you are as a person can be
judged by your capacity to put up with
things
man that's an easy virtue tolerance
the great thing about the the so-called
virtue of tolerance is that you can be a
virtuous person while laying on your
couch eating doritos
because when you do that you're
tolerating everything
when you see something bad happening and
you look the other way that's tolerance
you're being tolerant
so it's a great virtue for cowards and
lazy people
and that's why it's not a real virtue at
all
she's displaying
righteous intolerance here
by removing it now they could go and put
up the filth again sure but then you
know we should just take it down again
back and forth back and forth until they
get the message
that's what the other side would do
and has done
the only question is whether we want to
continue abiding by rules that they
don't abide by
they see something they don't like and
they just say i'll just take it down
that's it i'll take it down
even if it's a
150 year old statue
i'll get a crowd of people
we'll we'll take we'll use some straps
and we'll just we'll pull the thing down
should we handicap ourselves with this
weird notion of
decorum i mean there's there's
appropriate times for decorum i think
this is an inappropriate time
should we do that while the other side
rides through the land doing as they
please
now of course you might argue that this
is not a matter of mere decorum perhaps
this is a matter of rights you might say
in fact i've i've seen people on the
right make this argument in response to
this heroic woman in the subway the
subway avenger as i have just now
decided to call her they said that
okcupid has private property rights
and free speech rights
and that this woman has infringed on the
rights of the poor degenerates over at
okcupid by behaving in this way
today to that i think there are two
responses
first one is
even if that's true who cares
but second it's not true
you don't have any fundamental right to
plaster filth and degeneracy in public
areas
you don't have any fundamental right
to flood society with this kind of
sewage
you have the legal right yes nobody
disputes that i mean there's no question
that this woman committed a crime at
least vandalism i mean at least a
misdemeanor um according to the law no
doubt about that
but then again
uh and and if she's charged with a crime
and faces any legal trouble then i'll
want to know where her gofundme is so i
can donate to it and also post it and
get more people to donate to it but
but then again in most states except
texas
there's also no question that doctors
who kill children in the womb have not
committed a crime according to the law
does that mean they have an actual
fundamental human right to do what
they're doing
no
because while legal rights are granted
by the government
human rights actual rights upon which
our legal rights are supposed to be
based
are granted by god
if they're not granted by god then the
concept of human rights makes no sense
it has no meaning
the people who first developed the
concept of human rights certainly
thought that they were derived from the
creator
if they were wrong about that
then they were probably wrong about
human rights existing at all
in which case our legal rights are
entirely arbitrary and you have no deep
moral calling to respect them if we have
no fundamental god-given human rights
then when we talk about rights we just
mean
this is what the government says the
people in charge of the government right
now say this is what you can do this is
what you can't do
and you might respect that because
you're afraid of because they use force
and you're afraid of the force they
might use on you if you don't respect it
but there's no deeper
moral obligation to respect it
because it's arbitrary
but if rights are derived from god
then the question is whether god
desires for okay cupid to promote
pansexuality
and non-monogamy and pornography on the
subway
the question really we could boil it
down to this is
whose side do you think god is on
the people who put those posters up
or the woman who tore him down
i think the answer to that question
is uh is very clear
and we need to start thinking about
things in these terms
we know what the government says
we also know who's in charge of the
government
you know we know what the ruling class
is all about
um
we know what they say our our rights are
and our rights aren't
but where do these rights actually
derive from
who whose authority are we are we in the
end going to ultimately respect
god's authority or the government's
authority
and that's why today i rather than
canceling that woman i join her in
canceling okcupid which she has already
done such a fantastic job of doing
and we'll leave it there for today on
you know i don't know if i call it a
positive note as positive as you're
going to get on this show if you enjoyed
this video be sure to give it a thumbs
up and share it with all your friends